أو سأبدأ معك ،
لقد كنت تعمل على مصادرك في
البنتاغون ،
ماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا عن هذه
الضربات الجوية ، كما قلت إن هذه هي
أول ضربة عسكرية معروفة قادمة من
الرئيس جو بايدن
وزير الدفاع لويد أوستن قال
كما قال  كان عائدًا من رحلة إلى
الساحل الغربي بناءً على
توصيته ، لكن بايدن
أعطى التفويض النهائي في وقت سابق
اليوم بضربة جوية على طول
الحدود العراقية
السورية في سوريا شرق سوريا التي
كان الهدف مدعومًا من إيران  المليشيات الشيعية التي
كانت
تعمل هناك ويأتي ذلك بعد
سلسلة من الضربات الصاروخية التي
استهدفت مناطق مختلفة معنا
وقوات التحالف في أربيل
في قاعدة بلد الجوية شمال
بغداد ثم في المنطقة الخضراء في
بغداد نفسها
كان أوستن هو الذي قال إن  المواقع
التي
تم استهدافها هنا تم استخدامها من قبل
الميليشيات الشيعية المدعومة من إيران
التي يعتقد أنه واثق من
شن تلك الهجمات الصاروخية
ضد القوات الأمريكية.  قال مسؤول دفاعي أمريكي
إن ما يصل إلى حفنة من المسلحين
قتلوا في هذه الضربات
وهم ينتظرون معرفة المزيد من
المعلومات وتقييم أضرار المعركة ،
لكن
هذا ما قاله الوزير أوستن في
وقت سابق من هذا المساء بقليل ،
نحن على ثقة من أن ذلك  تم استخدام الهدف من
قبل الميليشيا الشيعية نفسها
التي نفذت الضربات
، وقد سمحنا وشجعنا العراقيين على التحقيق
وتطوير المعلومات الاستخبارية وكان ذلك
مفيدًا جدًا لنا
في تحسين الهدف ،
ويقول المتحدث باسم البنتاغون جون كيربي إن هذه
الضربة تمت بالتنسيق مع
مع
الحلفاء في المنطقة ، لا تتردد في
طرح سؤال آخر لك أو ما الذي
يخبرك به هذا عن الاستراتيجية
العسكرية الأكبر للرئيس بايدن
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالشرق الأوسط ،
فنحن نعلم جيدًا السؤال
الكبير للإدارة الأمريكية لإدارة بيدن
وحلفائنا في
المنطقة  هي
إيران وكيفية التعامل مع إيران ، فالمسألة ليست مجرد
مسألة ما يجب القيام به دبلوماسيًا
عسكريًا مع إيران  البرنامج النووي
يتجاوز الصواريخ الباليستية
الإيرانية تصرفات إيران في المنطقة ، والتركيز
والتركيز الرئيسي هنا هو إيران
بالتأكيد هناك أسئلة أخرى عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالشرق الأوسط ، ما الذي
ستفعله إدارة بايدن عندما يتعلق الأمر باليمن.
سوريا ولكن
المظلة الشاملة هنا
هي إيران وهذا هو المكان الذي سيكون فيه التركيز
وهذا هو السبب في أن هذا حساس للغاية لدرجة
أنه لم يكن ضربة ضخمة واسعة النطاق
يبدو أنها كانت ضربة محسوبة صغيرة نسبيًا
تهدف إلى التأكد من
أن إيران و  يعلم وكلائها في المنطقة
أن هناك تكلفة على الهجمات الصاروخية المستقبلية
ضد القوات الأمريكية ،
ولكن أيضًا ردًا على هذه
القوات السابقة بشكل حاسم ، لم يكن
القصد منها تصعيد الموقف الذي لم
يكن هدف إدارة بايدن ،
وهذا ما قاله جون كيربي البنتاغون
المتحدث وهذا يعطيك فكرة أن
النهج الحقيقي هنا
والنهج الأساسي سيكون
الدبلوماسية أولاً العسكرية
الثانية